I am no one to see an undigested food in my stools.
How do I address this?
So you have to understand the process
of when you put food in your mouth,
you're chewing your food.
That's part of the digestive process.
So there's two things that take place
in your digestion and absorption.
So, and then ultimately, elimination.
So, digestion is the breaking down of the food
into particle size that can be absorbed.
So, if you're seeing undigested food in your stools,
then, you know, start with top.
Are you chewing your food well enough?
That's number one.
If you're having issues with your parotid gland,
like you mentioned, then the parotid gland releases
enzyme called battalion, which helps digest
primarily carbohydrates.
So, if you're not getting,
you're missing a little bit of piece of digestion right there.
Then, this will nest to go into your stomach.
And the stomach does not create enzymes,
but it creates hydrochloric acid.
So, you can't do anything about, you know,
helping with the battalion secretion.
It's your parotid glands.
But you can do something about helping with the HCl
in your stomach.
So, taking hydrochloric acid with a digestive enzyme
with each meal is the thing to do.
So, food isn't getting properly digested.
Lame your HCl production.
Lame your enzyme production.
Enzymes are produced in the pancreas.
And then also some in the liver,
but the bile from the liver that's secreted
into the gallbladder, that's secreted into the dewandum,
helps break down fats, as well as the lipase,
which is an enzyme from the pancreas,
and the other enzymes from the pancreas,
the proteases, break down proteins,
and the amylases break down carbohydrates.
So, it's your pancreas, it's your liver,
it's your stomach, and in a small part,
your parotid gland, that digest your food.
So, you need to help support it by taking hydrochloric acid
and digestive enzymes.
Well, I've been taking that, but I'm still seeing this
and I'm still getting bloated.
Take more.
Do things to heal your gut.
Go to the blog post that talks about
hypochloridria, and you'll see details of that.
Go to the detoxification course,
and you'll see the details of the processes
of detoxification, which has to do
with the processes of digestion.
So, if you are seeing, I mean, there's some things
so if you are seeing, there's some things
that you will see in the process.
I mean, corn isn't digested very well.
There's some things that you will see in your stools.
So, don't get alarmed if there's some things
you see in your stools, but if you're noticing,
if you got major gut issues and bloated issues,
like you're saying you have,
then, you know, first thing you want to look at
is am I digesting, am I breaking down the food?
Well it up to absorb it.
Am I working on healing the gut?
Because if I'm not breaking down the food,
well it up to absorb it.
I'm causing irritation of the gut.
Have I done some tests like the Syrex Array 10 test
to see if I'm actually eating good food
that I actually have antibodies again?
So, every time I eat it, I'm causing inflammation.
So, even if I am producing enough digestive enzymes
in HCL, the inflammation that's going out
in the gut is preventing proper digestion
and proper absorption.
So, running some of these other tests
can be extremely helpful.
That's the Syrex Array 10 that I suggest.